ATTACK.
ALL SIGNS POINT TO RUSSIA.
HERE WITH MORE THE FORMER ENERGY
SECRETARY AND TEXAS GOVERNOR
RICK PERRY WITH NEWT GINGRICH.
GOVERNOR PERRY, THIS WAS
SOMETHING YOU AND NEWT GINGRICH
FELT STRONGLY ABOUT.
HOW IMPACTFUL IS THIS TO THE 17
STATES THAT ARE IN QUESTION
TONIGHT?
>> 45% OF THE GASOLINE GOING TO
THE EASTERN PART OF THE UNITED
STATES GOING THROUGH THAT
PIPELINE.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
SEAN, HERE'S THE REALLY
IMPORTANT THING FOR ME FROM THE
STANDPOINT -- I AM SURE THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION AND BUSH
ADMINISTRATION AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ALL WORKED TO GET
AMERICA TO BE INDEPENDENT OF
OTHER COUNTRIES OF OIL AND GAS.
WE DID THAT UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WE NOT ONLY BECAME INDEPENDENT.
WE BECAME DOMINANT.
THIS ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
TAKE THAT AWAY.
STOP BUILDING PIPE LINES.
IF WAS OF A WAKE UP CALL,
PRESIDENT BIDEN, MAYBE WE SHOULD
BUILD MORE PIPELINES INSTEAD OF
SHUTTING THEM DOWN.
THIS WAS IT TODAY WITH THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE.
THIS IS INSANITY.
>> Sean: WITH THE STROKE OF
A PEN EXECUTIVE FIAT, THESE ARE
HIGH PAYING ENERGY JOBS AND
AMERICA BECAME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, GREAT FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND CAREER JOBS FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
MR. SPEAKER, WE NOW HAVE -- IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS ATTACK CAME FROM
RUSSIA AND AN UNHOLY ALLIANCE
BETWEEN THE CHINESE, RUSSIANS
AND IRANIANS FIGHTING AGAINST
ISRAEL.
ISRAEL IS UNDER FIRE TONIGHT.
I DON'T SEE JOE BIDEN FUNDING
THE PALESTINIANS AND GETTING
BACK IN THE IRANIAN DEAL HAVING
A POSITIVE EFFECT.
>> Sean: HANG ON.
>> I WILL JUST SAY, GOVERNOR
PERRY KNOWS MORE THAN I DO ABOUT
THE PIPELINE PART.
ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY PART,
WE OUGHT TO PASS A LAW
IMMEDIATELY THAT MAKES THIS KIND
OF HACKING SUBJECT TO A DEATH
PENALTY AND THE LAW SHOULD
INCLUDE A PROVISION THAT THE
PRESIDENT THROUGH A JUDICIAL
PROCESS SHOULD BE ABLE TO ORDER
THE KILLINGS OF ANYBODY OVERSEAS
WHO IS DOING THIS.
WE HAVE SPENT 15 YEARS ON
DEFENSE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY ARE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THEY ARE.
IF WE KNEW WHO THEY WERE, WE
WOULD HAVE NO MECHANISM TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
A GREAT COUNTRY CAN'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SAVAGE AND HAVE NO
CONSEQUENCES AND WAIT FOR THE
NEXT ATTACK.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
THIS OUGHT TO BE A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE.
WHAT ARE WE PREPARED TO DO TO
PROTECT AMERICA FROM OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENTS OR PRIVATE CITIZENS?
THIS IS AN INTOLERABLE
SITUATION.
>> Sean: HOW DOES IT GET TO
BIPARTISAN FUNDING IRAN AND
GETTING INTO A DEAL WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE INSPECTIONS?
THE CHINESE AND RUSSIANS ARE
GIVING IRAN WEAPONS AND THE 3
COUNTRIES ARE ALIGNED AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES AND ITS
ALLIES?
>> GOVERNOR PERRY WITH EXPLAIN
THIS IS MUCH MORE TECHNICAL
DETAILS.
THE NORTHEAST LOSING 45% OF ITS
OIL AND GAS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL SAY ENOUGH OF THIS.
WE WANT THIS COUNTRY PROTECTED.
WE WANT IT TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
WE WILL FIRE ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T
GET IN LINE.
PEOPLE WON'T TOLERATE THESE KIND
OF ATTACKS WHICH ARE A NEW KIND
OF WARFARE.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY ARE PRIVATE
OR PUBLIC CRIMINALS IT'S AN ACT
OF WAR AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES.
WE NEED TO REACT TO IT AS AN ACT
OF WAR AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO LOOK AT THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES AND THEIR
SENATORS AND SAY, YOU DON'T FIX
THIS, YOUR SUCCESSOR WILL.
I WON'T PUT UP WITH IT OR YOU IF
YOU DON'T FIX IT.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR PERRY, IT'S
LIKE CORPORATIONS DON'T PAY
TAXES.
THEY WILL PASS THEM ON TO THE
CONSUMER.
JOE BIDEN HAS A NEW GREEN NEW
DEAL AGENDA.
IT'S SOCIALIST.
WE ARE ENERGY DEPENDENT.
NOW WE WILL BE DEPENDENT AGAIN
AND EVERY CONSUMER ITEM TRUCKED
IN TO WHATEVER STORE IT HAPPENS
TO BE, WON'T CONCYBE
SUMERS P
HIGHER PRICES?
>> GET READY FOR INFLATION.
WHICH YOU LOOK AT NORTH CAROLINA
I THINK ABOUT A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR THAT DECLARED A STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
THINK ABOUT THE STATE OF NEW
MEXICO.
IT WILL BE DEVASTATED BECAUSE OF
THE FOSSIL FUEL DECISIONS MADE
IN THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK EVERYBODY IN NEW MEXICO
IS A DEMOCRAT ELECTED OFFICIAL.
THEY ARE WILLING TO THROW THEIR
STATE INTO THE TOILET TO SUPPORT
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE
THINK THEIR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE PEOPLE THEY REPRESENT.
NEWT IS CORRECT.
TALKING ABOUT THIS BEING AN
IMPORTANT NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
NOT ONLY THE ECONOMIC SIDE OF
PEOPLE AND STATES AND UNION
WORKERS, BUT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT WHO IS THIS REALLY HELP
SOMETHING WELL, IT IS HELPING
THE CHINESE.
THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS IT DO
WITH AMERICAN FOSSIL FUEL AND
RELY UPON THE RENEWABLE SIDE OF
THINGS.
PART OF YOUR PORTFOLIO BEING
RENEWABLES MAKES SENSE, BUT THEY
ARE MOVING AWAY FROM EVERYTHING
THAT HAS TO DO WITH FOSSIL FUEL.
THIS GREEN NEW DEAL INSANITY.
THE PEOPLE THIS HELPS IS CHINAA.
60% OF SOLAR PANELS COME FROM
CHINA.
SO THE IDEA THAT WE AREA -- WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS.
THE SPEAKER IS RIGHT.
IT WILL TAKE DRASTIC MEASURES.
WE NEED TO SEND A CLEAR AND
POWERFUL MESSAGE.
IF YOU COME INTO THE US AND
ATTACK US WITH CYBER METHODS,
YOU WILL PAY A HUGE AND HEAVY